president trump's covet 19 diagnosis
coming just one month until the
presidential election
so how will the trump campaign stay
visible for the remainder of the race
joining me now senior advisers to the
trump 2020 campaign and co-authors of
the brand new book
trump america first corey lewandowski
and david bosse corey david
uh thank you both for being here uh
let's start on
on the president's side and then we'll
get to the political uh implications of
this
i sat one row in front of you both in
the rose garden for the nomination
of amy coney barrett you've been around
the president uh recently
uh corey if you would take us inside
that your own personal considerations as
well as kind of the inner circle around
the president right now
you know pete you did have a much better
seat than us because you're much more
important so congratulations on that
uh but look here's the truth pete and
you know this and the listeners should
know this
every time you walk on to the white
house complex you are tested for cova 19
we were tested yes on saturday before
that rose garden ceremony
i was with the president on wednesday at
a private fundraiser i was tested before
i even walked into the door to the
facility
and i was tested again yesterday here in
my home state of new hampshire
all three times i tested negative focova
19 and those are the protocols and
precautions
that the team has had in place to keep
the president and the first family safe
so that has what that is what has
happened so far and i'm sure they're
going to continue to look at those
protocols
to make sure that they can continue to
keep him safe
david the campaign continues the running
the country continues
uh will there be any change in the way
things operate in the white house or the
campaign
pete i think uh we just went through
this with the lockdown
in the spring right so the campaign had
had to transition from a
traditional campaign that we were doing
uh to a
a virtual campaign and now we're going
to shift back to that bill stephen
uh and his team are going to be leading
that and
and corey and i are going to be standing
there helping
bill uh do this every minute of every
day
every single one of us every trump
supporter in the country has to pick up
the banner
and help out right now you're looking
you look in maryland right now
there are people organically showing up
in front of walter reed showing their
love
to this president it's an amazing thing
to see
absolutely corey how uh speak to the
political side of this what's the
balance the president's at walter reed
has the ability to run
um you know the country from there has a
campaign to run
what's your advice on how visible he
should be in the coming days
well pete we know that the president has
a very unique communication style
whether he is in person
with a number of thousands of supporters
or he's calling into shows or he's
tweeting or using a social media
activity
i am certain that over the course of the
next many days
we will continue to hear from the
president he's put out a few tweets he
put out a video yesterday
so the one thing that is certain is this
president's going to continue to
communicate directly with the american
people
he will continue to give progress
updates i had the chance to speak with
chief of staff meadows last night
about how the president was doing it
walter reed he said he was in great
spirits and
he's ready to continue to fight every
day for the american people he's going
to beat covet
he's a warrior then he's going to keep
fighting for the american people every
day
david along those lines any reason to
believe the debate doesn't happen
anything going forward that you think
changes
no the debates are going to happen
there's no reason for them not to if
they have to
be pushed the second debate has to be
pushed a day or two
that's that's nothing we need this
president to recover
but he's a fighter and he's a fighter
for the american people that's why he
was elected
to begin with and he is a he is such a
fighter
he's going to beat covid and joe biden
all at the same time
so we're looking forward uh to the next
30
days of this campaign of telling the
american people
the good news of what his
accomplishments have been
and what he's done to lower their taxes
to make their lives better
to bring jobs back to america it's a
great story
none of that changes his list of
accomplishments isn't
like nothing that we've ever seen and
he's done more in 47 months
than joe biden's done in 48 47 years
nothing
about covid is going to change those
facts
real quick corey to the particulars and
do you expect virtual events uh do you
expect him
to call into shows uh what you know
anything in particular you can give us a
glimpse of you know peter
it's to be determined but i do think
you're clearly going to see the
president calling into shows
doing potentially telephone town hall
rallies continue to communicate
there is no virus that's going to stop
this president from continuing
to talk to the american people directly
he's done it so successfully over the
last six years since the campaign
started
this is not going to stop him at all
all right guys will you speaking of
success you've had some very successful
books in the past congratulations
on trump america first it's available
now hopes folks will check it out corey
lewandowski david bosse
thank you both for being here really
appreciate it